all right let's start today with sort of
an audience question I think it's a good
one this is exactly the type of question
I love to answer a viewer who I guess
goes by the name smash wrote to me about
the 2020 election and said dear David
you believe the 2020 election was not
stolen and there is no evidence to the
contrary what would you accept as
evidence what would it take to convince
who it was stolen hope you can answer
these questions thanks this is a fair
question because I would be a hypocrite
and I don't want to be a hypocrite in
front of all of you fine folks if I
demanded that sort of uh consideration
from others what evidence would change
your mind and then refuse to answer or
explain it myself and remember very
often if the answer is there is no
evidence that would change my mind
you're not really thinking so what
evidence would change my mind the first
thing whenever you have a conversation
like this and maybe this will be useful
to some to some people when we say
evidence what are we even talking about
and so to be very clear
for me to be convinced that there was
um an orchestrated voter fraud or
election fraud wherein Donald Trump was
the real winner but Joe Biden stole it I
would need evidence of some kind of
systematic voter fraud so the fact that
we found a bunch of Republicans you know
a dozen or so who either voted twice
there's the guy who's a junior and he
voted for himself and for his dad senior
who is no longer alive uh or we find you
know a Democrat that voted legally via
absentee ballot and then died by
election day like none of those things
are proof of systematic fraud and not
only do they not rise mathematically to
the theft of an election from Donald
Trump it's also just like a random
person okay so that that's the first
important thing we are looking for
evidence of systematic voter fraud here
and I would even go further and say
systematic voter fraud that would have
materially changed the results in at
least one state not even the entire
thing but at least one state okay there
are two types of claims that the
proponents of these conspiracy theories
often make
the first type of claim is that
sometimes the big lie people will make a
claim that something happened and that
thing did happen but it just isn't
actually voter fraud even at the
individual level never mind some kind of
systematic voter or election fraud so
I'll give you an example they say
hundreds of thousands of people were
registered in two places or usually it's
like at the state level they'll say tens
of thousands of people were registered
at two different addresses that's not
evidence of any kind of fraud it's not a
crime it's really common that when
people move they remain registered at
the old place if they showed up and
tried to vote at the old place they
would be allowed to
but they also might be registered at the
new place as long as you don't vote
twice there's no issue and there's no
crime so all of the allegations from the
right about things that are true but
aren't actually a problem those I don't
consider evidence of voter fraud because
they're quite literally not fraud
another example is they say State
legislatures changed voting rules
without altering the state constitution
well that's true but that's legal you
might not like it you might disagree but
under the public health emergency of
covid in 2020 there were state
legislatures that voted without altering
the state constitution to expand
absentee ballot or whatever
it's not a crime it's not illegal and
it's not evidence of voter fraud so
that's one bucket things that happened
but aren't actually evidence of voter
fraud those don't change my mind all
right then we get to the claims of
um anomalies anomalies anomalies your
preference okay like for example
hundreds of thousands of people didn't
really vote but they're they show up as
having voted
there has been no proof of those claims
there just has no proof of that so if
you can bring to me proof of some kind
of a systematic requesting and
submitting of absentee ballots by
someone and you've got to tell me who
the someone is without the knowledge of
the actual voter
in More Than This Minute number of cases
where it seems to be a paperwork error
then that I would consider that uh
substantial
if you were in and it can't be
we don't know who did it
and we don't know who the people are but
here's three people who say I got an
absentee ballot but I didn't ask for it
okay there were places that just sent
them out that's not fraud either okay so
if you can come to me with evidence that
listen we have found an IP address from
which a hundred thousand absentee
ballots ten thousand twenty thousand
something were requested and Mass
sent somewhere intercepted by someone
who filled them all out and sent them
all in oh now we're talking about
something we do not have that
um proof of people voting in multiple
locations that I would be interested in
not just your registered in two places
not illegal Trump's Tiffany Trump that
applied to Tiffany trump it applied to
Mark Meadows that's not actually against
the law if you had actual forensic
digital evidence of voting machines
being used in a nefarious way you know
you've got Mike pillow talking about the
machines and you've got all these claims
about Dominion did this no proof a
smartmatic did that no proof okay if you
present actual evidence that we can
subject to a digital forensic specialist
who can say hey you know what here's
proof here is proof of the manipulation
here's ten thousand people who try to
vote for Trump
and their votes were counted for Biden
and that has not been presented okay
felons voting in large numbers on
purpose mobilized by someone right like
five felons voting illegally because
they either didn't know they weren't
allowed to vote or even deliberately
right that's not actually evidence of
fraud at any real scale it wouldn't make
a difference in even a single state and
there's no evidence that it's
coordinated by anybody in the election
fraud sort of mode that these
Republicans claim the other thing is you
have to explain to me
how the relationship between the
population of a state
the known number of registered voters
the number of people that turned out and
very importantly remember the people
that voted presidential and down ballot
there is complete coherence between the
presidential vote counts and the votes
for Senate or house Etc if there were
some coordinated voter fraud of this
kind you would expect that if they just
messed with the presidential voting
alone there would be this completely out
of sync uh um uh these out of sync
results between presidential and Senate
or house or whatever the margins are
completely reasonable in all of these
and the Republicans never like to
explain well
I won my election legally on the same
ballot in which it was stolen from Trump
oh okay so the ballots only some of the
votes were fraudulent but the down
ballot stuff it's completely incoherent
one of the important themes or ideas I
think that's worth mentioning here is
something that Dr Stephen Novella writes
about in his I forget the name of the
book it's like Skeptics Guide or
something like that it's called anomaly
hunting and very often you will hear
actually the perfect example is the
umbrella man from the JFK assassination
and Dr Novella talks about this in his
book
after the assassination of JFK
pictures turned up with a guy holding an
umbrella on the grassy knoll or you know
on the side of the parade route at which
John F Kennedy was killed and you had
people who started to say it was a sunny
day
there's no reason someone would have an
umbrella and so they start to build up a
picture that goes something like what
are the odds that we have a presidential
parade and the president is assassinated
and we're told this story of a lone
gunman up in the window and there's a
guy with a huge umbrella on a sunny day
right alongside where JFK was killed he
must be involved because that's so
anomalous
but as Dr Steven Novella explains
the question should be a different one
the question should be because that does
make it sound nefarious in some way but
what if we you reframe the question and
you said what are the odds that at a
presidential parade
with so many attendees you find someone
who looks out of place for no
particularly nefarious reason when you
ask it like that a guy with an umbrella
doesn't sound so Sinister and of course
we later found out that the guy with the
umbrella the umbrella was a political
protest I believe it was a political
protest against uh maybe Robert Kennedy
I don't remember exactly so you have to
also understand that you know if I said
to you look at this thing that happened
that's a one in an eight million chance
you would say oh my God that's got to be
something is going on there something is
acting on that one in eight million
things are so rare New York City has
eight million people that means every
single day
there could be a one in eight million
occurrence and it would be
mathematically expected and so a lot of
this stuff that these people look for is
sifting through data to find something
that sounds unlikely but the reality is
that when you have however many million
votes we had 170 million 180 million
more less something
um you can find seeming anomalies and
they don't really mean anything okay so
hopefully that gives a sense of what I
would accept as proof that the 2020
election was stolen one of our sponsors
today is BusyBox child I know that there
are many parents in our audience this is
for you busy box child offers really
great subscription boxes for kids filled
with sensory toys that will help your
toddler to Elementary age child stay off
screens and do some really interesting
stuff technology use by kids is at an
all-time high especially after the
pandemic playing off of screens is
really critical for development for
cognitive development social emotional
well-being for kids it's an ideal
opportunity for parents to engage with
kids as well Carolyn is the founder of
busy box child she's a mom and a child
clinical psychologist who designs all
the boxes that you receive busy box
child offers monthly sensory kits with
different themes for each season or you
can get a monthly sand bin subscription
for hours and hours of fun check out
their mini jars and mini kits for
playtime on the go BusyBox child is a
small business that supports the David
packman show support them go to
busyboxchild.com and use the code Pacman
for 10 off the link is down below